and before i ask you any questions i'm
gonna tell you i just talked to jay
farrell and i said jay what are you most
excited to see tonight and he said you
no way
oh that means a lot he's awesome i had
to share
um so you're co-chairing this thing with
robert pattinson what are you most
excited for oh my gosh i mean it's a
celebration of filmmakers and um i'm i'm
a big um i'm big on storytelling you
know in every way music art and i i'm
just happy to be celebrating celebrating
that and i've never met rob so tonight
will be our first time meeting and i'm
excited yes i'm a big fan
what are you most excited to see inside
this place oh my gosh i don't even know
like i'm i just want to be surprised
like i want to see all the and i know
it's like thematic it's not like in
chronological which i think is going to
be really dope so i'm excited to see how
the moods are
if you could put one thing from your
career in that building what is it what
do you take oh my gosh honestly i've
kind of already left my mark on here i
did my oscar performance in this
building so that i've already put my my
little stamp give me a memory back from
that oscar performance that must have
been special for you oh man you know
honestly we we shot it the day that um
the george floyd the verdict came and um
it was it was a very intense um day but
um i think it drove us in our
performance and it made it even more
special
wow that's incredible um i wanna ask you
about one more thing before you go
brittany seems to be getting her freedom
back today how do you feel about that i
feel great you know um women are
constantly oppressed i think uh
we we lose a lot of our control
sometimes so i think it's good to see
and it's good to hear